hello IMAX movie goes hey IMAX fans I'm
gonna show you something
[Music]
show time a whole IMAX is just a
completely immersive viewing experience
the aspect ratio is probably more well
suited for Marvel movies enos for
anything because there's a lot of
verticality of character IMAX up close
is the greatest thing ever because the
frame disappears to fill more of the
screen
exclusively for IMAX theses maybe
sometimes you just want to hang out on
my face 60 feet why on an IMAX screen
IMAX what having TV screens smashed into
your face it's my favorite way to watch
that you will not see the full
experience unless you see the title it's
the spectrum is the objective in these
sorts of movies size matters
[Music]
the sound is incredible
the colors they're so rich
this film is best appreciated in an IMAX
rate
you just want to stand in front of it
and off
a lot of superheroes coming together
it's traumatic and powerful
sounds like the IMAX was the appropriate
call damn right
[Music]
[Music]